thomas hierbei bild da sind wir ja immer
näher an und mit unseren soldaten und
deswegen können wir an diesem morgen
eine exklusive jahr spezialkräfte
operation vermelden die in den letzten
24 stunden genau dort in kabul statt
gefunden hat denn unsere ksk-soldaten
das kommando spezialkräfte hat den
flughafen verlassen und eine münchner
familie die seit einer woche in kabul
ausgeharrt hat probiert hat selbst im
flughafen zu kommen von den taliban
bewaffnet gestoppt worden ist die haben
sie retten können und in den flughafen
reinholen können und eben diese familie
aus den händen aus dieser
gefahrensituation herausnehmen können
eine eine deutsche familie die dort
angehörige besucht hat oder die familie
ist aus münchen nach kabul gereist haben
auch bilder dieser familie gemeinsam
eben kurz nach der rettung mit dem ksk
auf die wir vielleicht noch mal schauen
können diese familie ist nach kabul
gereist weil man wollte die großmutter
noch mal besuchen die großmutter bevor
eben die k die die taliban das gesamte
land überrennen und man dort nicht mehr
hinkommt familie sind gereist die
tochter 19 jahre alt eine münchner
abiturientin ihr kleiner bruder zwölf
jahre alt und die mutter die waren dort
und dann ging alles viel schneller als
befürchtet wir haben wir darüber
berichtet dieser marsch der taliban und
dann war man plötzlich gefangen in
afghanistan in kabul kamen nicht mehr
raus ich habe es gesagt die familie
wollte zum flughafen da gab es eine
situation wo taliban in die luft
geschossen haben sie umgedreht sind und
jetzt also diese dramatische rettung von
der wir erfahren haben wir haben es ja
auch gesehen die lage wird immer
dramatischer
die situation heute morgen die
auseinandersetzungen das gefecht dass
die deutschen soldaten geraten sind sind
tausende immer noch da versuchen zum
flughafen zu kommen julian muss man
damit rechnen die amerikanische
regierung hat ja bereits auch darauf
hingewiesen muss man damit rechnen dass
es auch zu anschlägen kommt
selbstmordattentate beispielsweise in
der menge damit muss man auf jeden fall
rechnen deswegen sehen wir in diesen
dramatischen stunden und das ist das was
max uns gerade geschildert hat offenbar
einen kompletten wechsel der
vorgehensweise der spezialkräfte
internationalen spezialkräfte die dort
am flughafen von kabul stationiert sind
man fordert die eigenen staatsbürger
jetzt eindringlich auf kommt nicht mehr
zum flughafen und hat sich offenbar
darauf verständigt die staatsbürger das
gilt für die amerikaner das gilt aber
wie wir jetzt exklusiv berichten können
auch für die deutschen aus der stadt
heraus zu holen vollkommen anderes
konzept vollkommen andere
herangehensweise deutlich gefährlicher
als das was man vorher gemacht hat aber
nach allem was wir wissen vermutlich
auch die einzige möglichkeit der zeit
denn wir sehen die dramatischen bilder
von diesem northgate dem nördlichen tor
am flughafen in kabul vollkommen
überlastet verstopft menschenmengen in
den letzten tagen haben uns immer wieder
dramatische berichte erreicht von
kindern die dort zum beispiel
totgetrampelt worden sind und natürlich
ist das ein perfektes anschlagsziel für
die taliban wir haben den letzten tagen
schüsse dort eben die menge gesehen
deswegen die klare botschaft der
amerikanische und der deutschen
streitkräfte an die eigenen staatsbürger
bleibt zu hause sagt uns wo ihr seid und
wir holen euch dort ab das ist ich hoffe
wir können unseren zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern gleich noch mal die fotos
zeigen tatsächlich mit der
spektakulärste was das ksk in seiner
geschichte bisher geleistet hat und mit
sicherheit auch mit das gefährlichste
mann muss sich das noch mal vorstellen
die arbeiten sich zu fuß vor in ein
gelände das wissen wir was von taliban
umstellt ist wo du nicht weißt wer ist
hinter der nächsten straßenkreuzung
hinter der nächsten ecke wo du auch
erstmal eine kontaktaufnahme schaffen
muss mit deutschen die du womöglich zu
einem bestimmten punkt feuer bestellt
hast das sind alles hoch dramatische
momente wo man nur froh sein kann dass
wir in diesem moment genau diese einheit
die soldaten dort vor ort haben nun wird
uns ja immer unterstellt wie bei bild
hier sind so militär begeistert ihr wart
beide dort in afghanistan aber es in der
tat eine extrem wichtige aufgabe die die
bundeswehrsoldaten dort waren ja das ist
ja eine truppe des ksk das kommando
spezialkräfte das aus genau wie übrigens
auch die gsg9 aus einem dramatischen
scheitern hervorgegangen ist die gsg 9
mit den schrecklichen anschlägen von den
olympischen spielen in münchen 1972 nach
dem mann gesagt hat wir brauchen
spezialkräfte die uns in solchen terror
lagen helfen können das ksk anfang der
90er gegründet nachdem klar wurde
deutschland ist nicht in der lage
staatsbürger in gefahr staatsbürger die
geisel genommen wurden er aus
dramatischen situationen zu retten
seitdem trainiert diese truppe die in
den letzten monaten ja auch politisch
immer wieder schwer in der kritik stand
aber in diesen stunden sieht man was für
ein segen ist dass wir diese soldaten
haben ich durfte sie mal besuchen und
bei ihrer ausbildung begleiten genau wie
max glaube ich auch spannende zahl ein
kommando feldwebel das heißt die
soldaten die dort jetzt im alter im
einsatz sind verschießt in seiner
ausbildung 50 tausend schuss munition
allein in seiner ausbildung da kann man
sich ungefähr ausmalen wie hoch
trainiert diese leute sind üben
ausschließlich in diesen scharfen
szenarien und das scheint sich im moment
genau wie es sein soll sehr zum schutz
deutscher staatsbürger in kabul
ausgewirkt haben
[Musik]